good morning John I wonder thought this
out by saying that I'm not a doctor I'm
not a counselor I haven't experienced
sexual abuse I'm just a person with some
thoughts that hopefully could be helpful
to some sex is complicated in like every
way imaginable this is not aided by the
fact that we have a general societal
taboo against discussing it so when we
do talk about it it's often shrouded in
metaphors and innuendo and bombast isset
II it means a lot of the sexual norms of
our culture are mysterious and we don't
actually talk about them we just sort of
infer them I think that's dumb and
that's part of why I helped Nick and
Lindsey starts explanation I think that
our culture has kind of a messed up
relationship with sex we somehow have
made these relationships into like
predator-prey relationships like one
person is the you know cruise missile of
desire and the other one is this sweet
chaste little kid and the cruise
missiles have to get the Katyn and the
kitten runs away I don't know why it's a
cruise missile on a kid I do know though
that this is a dumb system I think that
a lot of the joy and Wonder and
excitement of a romantic relationship
comes from those moments of excitedly
discovering that both parties are into
this worry we're both into this that's a
great field the attack missile Kayden
relationship does not encourage that I
want to be clear I'm explaining culture
but I'm not excusing the behavior and
we're set up to assume that the Khitan
is gonna run whether the Khitan wants
the cruise missile or not that enables
abuse in my opinion this is I'm sure not
all of the reason but one of the big
reasons why sexual abuse is so common in
our culture okay I said sexual abuse but
what what is sexual abuse legally the
definition has to be very specific so
that it can stand up in court so it's
different state to state country to
country for the purposes of having a
general definition let's just say that
sexual abuse is when one party is being
coerced into doing something sexual that
they do not want to do that could be
because the victim is incapacitated
because the abuser is an authority
figure or because the victim is placed
in the dangerous situation where they
feel like they don't have the option of
saying no or getting out of the
situation the gender
of the parties is irrelevant it can be
sex it can be kiss if one person doesn't
want to be doing what they are doing and
they're being coerced or pressured into
doing it than that is abuse it is
ubiquitous and it needs to not be
because it holds us back as a culture
you have to rid ourselves of that
outdated and rotten conception that
sexual relationships are like
predator-prey things but zoom in for
this romantic relationships can be
wonderful but you have to have that
magical thing consent not saying no is
not the same as saying yes we need to
communicate we need to be sensitive we
need to talk about what we do and don't
want to do we have to respect and not
pressure people when they don't want to
do something this video is part of a
long conversation that is going to
continue to be had for a long time but
John and I have some ideas about how to
keep it moving first we've already
started working with a group of
nerdfighters including some survivors of
sexual abuse who will be working as a
task force against abuse and assault
second we want to produce and fund a
series of videos that discusses abuse
and consent and sexual relationships
especially in light of the new digital
world like where to Skype fit and do it
all right and third we're looking to
partner with some existing sexual
assault organizations to bring their
work and their resources into our
community and hopefully into other
online communities as well Jonna no
we're not going to fix the whole world
but I'm pleased to be in a position
where we can at least start to help
enable some positive change I'll see you
on Tuesday
if you're in an abusive relationship or
you think you might be and you're just
not sure there are links in the
description to help you figure out where
you're at and to people who you can call
or go to for help
sometimes just figuring out the abusive
nature of a relationship can be a huge
challenge and once you're in there it
can seem like it is impossible to escape
but it is not